what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into the iron
metropolitan what I want to do before we
start this is I want to run over the ten
rings of the Mandarin and the reason why
is because of the fact that what Karen
Gillan is going to do is basically turn
the rings of the Mandarin into the
equivalent of Lantern rings and Marvel
Comics now the reason why I say this is
because of the fact that the Rings
themselves are actually going to start
seeking out people in this particular
story and going into the rings of the
Mandarin and the lantern raised in DC
Comics serve the same purpose you have
the ability to instill great hope as the
Blue Lantern rings you have the ability
to instill great fear that's the
Sinestro Corps rings because of that
it's really one of these scenarios where
Marvel's is kind of borrowing from DC
but it's done in a way that still works
now with regards to the rings of the
Mandarin there are ten of them and each
of the Rings has his own distinct
property or ability that makes it
separate from any of the other rings now
in truth I compared all the information
from the Marvel wiki to the comics so
the Marvel wiki is actually right this
time um as the word is gonna kind of go
with Alyssa they have their but the
remake ur is basically a reign that
allows the Mandarin to manipulate the
atomic and molecular structure of matter
but it cannot transmute elements or
affect objects encased in force or
energy fields meaning it cannot turn
something into gold and if something's
behind a force field they can't do
anything to access it the influence ring
allows the Mandarin to generate and
project various beams of concussive
force pretty straightforward the spin
ring causes the air to move about at
high speeds like it were in a vortex and
the vortex can be used as an offensive
weapon as a means of levitating objects
or as a means of propelling the rings
wearer through the air basically giving
them the power of flight the spectral
ring allows the Mandarin to project a
beam of energy capable of destroying the
bonds between the atoms and molecules of
any particular object causing inanimate
objects to disintegrate the problem with
this is the ring has to recharge for 20
minutes after each use of course this is
basically a caveat that allows Marvel to
keep the Mandarin from being a guy who
can just manipulate matter on the atomic
scale anytime he wants to
now the night bringer ring allows the
Mandarin to create an area of Darkness
presumably using dark force energy to do
so now dark force energy is almost like
vantablack in a lot of different ways
those are you guys who don't know what
that is vantablack is a shade of black
that's so incredibly dark that anything
that's sprayed
with a color Fanta black basically just
looks like a hole in reality it's crazy
how dark it is like there's one image
circulating out there somewhere of a
basketball that was sprayed with an to
black and it looks like it's just a hole
in reality it's crazy how it looks like
it's really kind of mind-blowing but for
those of you guys who were reading
secret Empire a dark force energy is
what was used to basically in case all
of New York so that dr. strange in our
body was just kind of trapped in another
dimension so again it's really one of
these things were just harnesses other
dimensional power but the demonic ring
allows the Mandarin to generate and
manipulate various forms of
electromagnetic energy
the incandescence ring allows the
Mandarin to project blasts of infrared
and produce flame or ignite combustible
material the lyre which that's going to
be one of the more interesting rings in
this story magnifies the Mandarin
psionic energies allowing him to
mentally manipulate the thoughts and
actions of others and will actually hint
on how that was used by the Mandarin
himself here in a little bit the
lightning ring allows the Mandarin to
reject blasts of electrical energy it
literally does exactly what it sounds
like it generates lightning the zero
ring allows the Mandarin to project
waves of intense cold and ice including
trapping foes in ice blocks and sheaths
so it basically just kind of allows the
Mandarin to manipulate cold weather
that's really it it kind of like gives
them the power of ice man in a lot of
different ways now having run over that
list real quick
the whole basis behind the idea of
really iron metropolitan is to show us
what the potential could possibly be
with the arno and Stark Brothers
remember of course in the last video we
talked about how Tony Stark had learned
about his brother are now basically the
the genetically engineered brother
that's the biological child of Howard a
Maria Stark and that Tony himself was
basically just adopted and so again this
was really kind of cool because it
served two purposes and the first was
creating a more compelling story and the
second was actually bringing to us the
idea that Tony Stark is as smart as he
is because he's just that smart is just
genuine natural intelligence so again
it's kind of a cool scenario but with
regards to the future that really be
holds the earth for these two guys
remember Tony Stark was basically told
by recorder 4-5-1 prior to its death
more or less that the earth was a
potential beacon for peace across the
universe and we know just by virtue of
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers that
time will eventually come something like
10,000 years in the future 5,000 years I
don't know what it is but there's
actually a place called Avengers world
but with regards to getting to that
place what we end up have
is really like this limps 30 years into
the future where Tony Stark and Arno
have basically generated peace across
the planet earth they have this massive
city called Troy and this city basically
creates pure energy for the world to use
it really creates a kind of utopia the
downside to this is that they currently
have an AI called
Helen and Helen is model largely after
recorder 451 but as Tony Stark puts it
was designed to basically stay away from
all the glitches and the mistakes that
will come along with artificial
intelligence of course this turns out
not to be the case Helen goes awry and
begins the process of tearing up
everything that Tony Stark an honour
star can built now of course in response
to this they end up sending out you know
some 20,000 Iron Man suits they're
piloted by the a is modeled after Pepper
Potts after James Rhodes but in the end
it doesn't make any difference
everything they've worked for has been
destroyed and so what we end up learning
is that this is actually a simulation
that both are no Stark and Tony Stark
are experiencing and in every single
instance of this simulation the AI Helen
that they create ultimately goes awry
now the reason why this is important is
because starker I guess Tony and Arno
take two different stances on this our
nose response is you cannot toy with AI
every single simulation we've run the AI
will always become sentient and it'll
always run amok and Tony Stark's mind
there's going to be a way around it
there's got to be a way to basically set
up that AI so it will not go down that
path it will not become a villain more
or less so again it's really kind of
wild because we learned that Tony Stark
had basically brought you know record a
4-5-1 back to earth for the purpose of
really doing nothing more than just kind
of experimenting on and learning about
the technology that it has because
remember what that recorder having been
around for millions of years it
assimilated all different kinds of
technology from across the universe
technology that humanity hasn't even
experienced yet the only way to access
it is in recorder four five one so again
Tony Stark basically has preview to
technology and advances that humanity
would otherwise never have access to but
at the end of the day his mind is still
that they can create this utopia for the
world and they can literally transform
earth into a beacon of peace across the
universe but the first step is finding a
way to salvage and to access all the
technology within you know record a
4-5-1
and basically save earth itself and so
from here this is
we'll begin the process of switching
over to the idea of essentially Marvel's
version of the Green Lantern rings in
the sense that one of the Mandarin rings
arrives to a woman by the name of
Abigail Beryl burns who really goes by
the name red pearl essentially as you
know as she puts it she's really more of
like a journalist but she goes through
and writes about corporations that
engage in seedy actions and things like
that but she's really just kind of
pissed off at the world and like she
hates capitalism and different things
like that and so the result is that
she's given a ring and she's deemed to
be Mandarin seven and the idea is to
essentially take revenge against Tony
Stark now we don't really know why we
don't know why these rings are taking
revenge against Tony Stark and in fact
the Rings have never become sentient
before the Rings are only ever objects
that were used by the Mandarin to
basically fight against Tony Stark so
this is wholly new this is brand new
stuff bye bye Kieron Gillen and it's
actually really kind of cool to see it
all unfold but what we also end up
finding out here is the first stage -
Tony Stark's plan basically revamping
the world is traveling to Mandarin city
now this is kind of interesting because
when Matt Fraction first introduced
Mandarin city there wasn't really a
whole lot to go on there it was just
there one day you know the Mandarin just
kind of had a base of operations in
Mandarin city the only indication we
were given was that it was some place
off the coast of China that the Mandarin
presumably used some kind of CDE you
know means used you know his lyre ring
for example the ability to manipulate
the minds of others to basically give
himself that Island or to take it from
China and that was really it but during
the whole longwaydown storyline when the
Mandarin basically kidnapped both
Ezekiel Stane the son of ayodhya Stan
and Tony Stark and forced them to begin
building these giant you know mechanized
suits that would allow the Mandarin
essentially to engage in world
domination they effectively turned
against him but where Tony Stark was
working to defeat the Mandarin using
technology and taking down these various
powered suits - so on and so forth
Ezekiel Stane actually fought the
Mandarin and killed him and so what it
did is it basically left Mandarin city
with a giant power vacuum and so what
started happening is that all these
different warlords and these petty
criminals who were living under the
Mandarin began to vie for power and so
you had triad so you know who were
showing up you know these Asian base
gangs and so on and so forth and really
Mandarin city just kind of turned into a
giant war zone now Tony's start going in
here alongside our know Stark who's
basically piloting some of these large
armors is designed for the purpose of
basically clearing
city out seizing control of a mandarin
city and then basically turning and into
like this refuge turning it into this
this safe haven and so what we end up
doing is we travel to basically the core
which is you know within mandarin city
more or less and what we have Tony start
doing is taking the pepper AI removing
her from him putting her inside the core
of this system and renaming her Helen
and so because of this it's really kind
of Tony Stark falling down the path of
becoming the guy that's eventually going
to lead to this helen robot losing its
mind destroying everything so again it's
almost one of these scenarios where it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy from
here we kind of skip forward you know a
little bit or at least we kind of pick
up in the modern day we're started
previously you know kind of cleared out
Mandarin city but the fact remains with
all the construction and everything
that's taking place here once Mandarin
city is basically cleaned out and once
it's renamed to Troy we end up of course
having Tony Sarg making a declaration to
all those who are present making a
declaration to the press that Troy is
going to serve as a beacon is going to
serve as a place where those people who
are living in destitution those people
who are living in squalor they can leave
their struggling areas and they can come
to a place that's new now this is really
kind of cool because it's really one of
those scenarios where Marvel are really
curing Guillen's building on what's
already been established and that's
really kind of the way it goes
in Marvel Comics there was really a
place called asteroid M or Avalon
depending on on what you choose to call
it that was created by Magneto and it
was designed to be a safe haven for
mutants away from the oppressive regime
of humanity now of course this basically
put humanity in a state of fear when you
end up having you know almost all forces
basically withdrawing from an area that
means something really bad is going to
happen and so because of that you know
Humanity looking at it from a wartime
perspective believe that you know
magneto was pulling all the mutants off
of Earth because he was in turn going to
like cleanse the earth in his entirety
just eradicate everybody on earth so of
course humanity struck against against
Magneto magneto struck back issued a
blanket EMP around the planet the x-men
intervened and that led into fatal
attractions when Wolverine lost his
adamantium so again it was really kind
of a cool cool scenario in terms of how
it all kind of unfolded and what led to
what and different things like that but
this is still very much the same thing
you know Tony Stark going into an
existing territory that's basically in a
state of flux co-opting it and then
making it his own the issue at this is
that while all this goes down we end up
finding out another ring had basically
bonded to somebody else this person
going by
mandarin one now of course we don't know
who this person is but Tony Stark
immediately recognizes the signatures of
the ring now of course abigail takes
this opportunity to effectively attack
Tony Stark so it's really more on an
alliance without an intention to be in a
life so so she's just kind of like
jumping into the moment and using the
distraction as a way to basically take
on Stark now force donning his Iron Man
suit we end up finding out how far stark
is calm because remember all of this
comes out of extremists and so while
Tony Stark had long since abandoned the
extremist technology the fact remains
here that what he ends up doing is
basically creating a stealth suit for
himself that he's been wearing the
entire time it's just you didn't know it
was there because it's a stealth suit so
it's actually kind of cool but from here
things are pretty straightforward I mean
in the sense that he's able to run off
you know Abigail for time and basically
kind of retreat and that's really about
it and so the question that Tony Stark
has is if that was a ring of the
Mandarin then what happened to the rings
of the Mandarin now the reason why we
asked that question is because of the
fact that the Rings are extremely
dangerous and they're not like Lantern
rings right like like if you were
someone who just walked up and picked up
a Green Lantern ring if you're not if it
doesn't deem you as being a person
that's worthy to wield it you wouldn't
be able to use it the rings of the
Mandarin don't work that way anybody can
put it on and suddenly they've got all
the powers that come along with it
and so what Tony Stark does is alongside
James Rhodes investigate the shield
weapons vault Omega now this is a
multi-faceted fault and the reason why
is because of the fact that if you've
ever wondered what happens to like the
weapons of massive villains who launch
an attack and they're defeated and so on
and so forth but they're all basically
stationed in different vaults and
there's a lot of places like that around
the Marvel Universe but because the
rings of the Mandarin do not require any
measure of worth in order to be able to
use them or at least previously they
didn't once xx Stark and James Rhodes
begin to go there and they basically
start looking around they see all the
rings that are there but having an AI
scan it means that the AI will see
what's truly there and will not see what
their eyes see and this is when we
learned that the liar ring had basically
been duping everybody that once a week a
member of shield will go down there they
will investigate they'll check and make
sure all the rings are there and if they
are they'll seal everything back up and
they'll leave the liar ring had
basically been making it appear as
though all the rings were there to the
human eye messing with people's
psychological mindsets but an AI doesn't
have a psychological mind is literally
just tack and so because of that Tony
Stark and James Roday basically informed
all the other reigns of the Mandarin are
just out there of course the liar ring
being the last one to take off and do
its own thing now again this is kind of
wild because the Rings are essentially
becoming sentient that's never happened
before again we're in uncharted
territory here and so what we end up
finding out here is that where abigail
or red peril of course has been chosen
the wheel to one of the reins of the
Mandarin her allegiance is not so cut
and dry and that's what makes things
kind of cool it's because usually in
Marvel Comics when a villain or when a
person has given absolutely power and
they have an agenda they usually become
a bad guy abigail is not that way she
got a ring of the Mandarin and she has
this rings abilities but she's a
journalist first and whatever she is now
second a villain or an antihero whatever
you want to call her and so her idea is
to investigate the city what's really
going on does Tony Stark have an
ulterior motive or is he actually doing
the right thing and what we end up
finding out is that the way this city is
designed to function this design to
basically create perpetual energy is
designed to be a city where people won't
have to pay utility bills where it'll
basically feed people by generating food
they won't have to go and buy groceries
it'll be 100% self-contained renewable
system and that's something no one's
ever seen before this is a tried and
true utopia and once abigail begins to
realize this this is when she comes to
the conclusion that the city is quite
literally designed to make everything
better for anybody who's in it so Tony
Stark is actually benefiting humanity
instead of profiteering off humanity and
so what this does is it really changes
the perspective that Abigail has of Tony
Stark she still looks at him as just
kind of like a weapons manufacturer and
a profiteer but in this instance he's
trying to do the right thing and so
tearing the city down would actually
hurt people as opposed to help them and
so what we end up having is basically
her being led to the other individuals
out there who have the rings of the
Mandarin for example a guy who has the
remake ER ring calls himself Lord remake
ER and so again because of this you know
this leaves really just kind of like a
massive conflict between you know these
other members of the Mandarin core and I
guess we could really kind of call the
Mandarin core but these are the members
of the Mandarin core Iron Man with
Abigail fighting alongside iron man this
is really kind of cool because again
she's very much an antihero here in the
sense that she's really kind of working
against Tony Stark as much as she's
working for him and this
that she's on his side but only for the
short term but in this massive conflict
the building that houses are no Stark
effectively comes crashing down so this
is kind of crazy because the implication
here was that this would be the death of
Arno stark and it would be kind of a
pretty lackluster scenario of that way
the case just because of the fact that
Arno has proven himself to be one of the
most intelligent members of the stark
family I mean really he's in a lot of
ways I would surmise smarter than Tony
Stark and so because of this noting that
Stark has done here with regards to
Mandarin City the city of Troy none of
this would be possible without our know
stark could just couldn't pull it off of
course we end up finding out that Arno
actually survived the blast and what
he's been doing is he had been working
on his own version of an Iron Man suit
but it's not really a traditional Iron
Man suit as we think of it instead it's
basically just a massive tank now of
course this is kind of funny because
it's half wish-fulfillment and a half
practicality one thing you got to think
of is that uh no starch spent his entire
life confined to a bed in an iron lung
and so all the intelligence and
everything he had more or less went to
waste because he could never use any of
it but it didn't keep him from imagining
what kind of life he could have in this
scenario with the work that they've done
with the other work that Arno stark and
the work that Tony Stark have done
together being attacked by this Mandarin
core we essentially have our know
building his own his own Iron Man suit
this like this massive battle tank and
just kind of like riding high into the
conflicts it is actually really cool to
see because again it's practical it's
not designed to be this super
maneuverable suit because there's
already a ton of those it's designed to
be a suit that can basically control the
different the different models that are
out there the reason be because of
course you know the Helen AI has more or
less been taken down at this point and
so because that the Iron Man suit is
kind of flying around on autopilot some
of them are being shot now and some of
them are shooting at the wrong targets
but having a suit ran by Arno that can
consolidate the AI of all these other
suits into a singular source means that
he can control all the other suits and
so what we end up having here is one of
the members of the Mandarin Corps
basically just kind of vanishes out in
nowhere and no one really knows where he
went to of course Abigail begins to poke
around and finds out that the guy has
been decapitated
not only that her hands are basically
cut off by some unknown source and her
ring is taken from her and so again what
it seems like is someone around there
somebody somewhere it's consolidating
all these Mandarin
unto themselves which begs the question
are they the ones that activated the
Mandarin rings in the first place
and made them sentient initially we're
not given this explanation instead all
we end up having is abigail without
hands of course her hands are basically
cut off but she continues to kind of
scream at Tony Stark about her you know
agenda and so on and so forth and that's
really about it but at the end of the
day because of the fact that Troy is
just kind of collapsed the way that it
does because of the fact that Abigail
made the case that look you're building
a city here that's great for everyone
that lives here but the target is always
you everybody's always coming after you
so long as you're here you're making
Troy a target because of that Tony Stark
basically kind of gets up on a podium
and says look you know I tried running a
city it was really too much of a hassle
so I quit and then just leaves and
that's really it instead he leaves the
running of the city to his brother Arno
Stark and so with that in mind what we
end up finding out here is that we're
the hands of Abigail were cut off one of
the members of the Mandarin Court was
decapitated the person who had done this
was actually Malekith via cursed of
course as we know one of the Dark Elves
from Sparta high and so what this does
is it basically brings vs guardians into
the mix and it really kind of asked the
question what would happen if a being
who's already godlike in terms of their
durability and strength were to gain
virtually godlike powers because of the
rings of the Mandarin so it's actually
really kind of cool to see how this
would unfold but if you guys are new
here two comments explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I'm gonna catch you all in it peace
[Music]